[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt wir haben eigentlich schon so kurz
vor feierabend als es schon später
nachmittag kurz vor dem abend und wir
uns gerade spontan überlegt wie wir
machen heute einfach rita ein schnelles
einfaches rezept was sie auch zuhause
hervorragend vorbereiten könnt und zwar
ist es eine gewürzmischung die ich euch
gleich zeigen die ihr zubereiten könnt
und damit zum beispiel hähnchen oder
auch andere fleischsorten und gemüse
eben schön marinieren könnt ich mache
das ganze jetzt so ich bereit eine
gewürzmischung zu nehmen dann hähnchen
und gemüse das ganze wandert in der
schüssel und kann dann eigentlich sofort
angebraten werden und dann kann es
direkt essen in raps zum beispiel oder
als beilage oder als hauptgericht und
dann reist dazu oder ihr könnt das ganze
auch vorbereiten im kühlschrank stellen
und wenn ihr dann nach der arbeit nach
hause kommt dann ist es ganz schön
durchgezogen ihr könnt auch grillen auf
dem grill zubereiten das ist wirklich so
ein bisschen auch food group also essen
was man gut vorbereiten kann für den
nächsten tag oder auch für den gleichen
abend und ich zeige euch mal kurz die
zutaten für die gewürzmischung habe ich
jetzt hier schon mal alles vorbereitet
ihr braucht doch für eine prise zimt
etwas salz und pfeffer koriander samen
und kreuzkümmel eine knoblauchzehe 1
esslöffel salz 2 esslöffel stärke 2 ist
paprika nimmt jetzt scharfes oder süßes
paprikapulver einen esslöffel
gemüsebrühe das ist hier die
selbstgemachte dann habe ich hier noch
balsamico essig und olivenöl 2 rote
zwiebeln paprika mix rot gelb und grün
und natürlich hähnchenfleisch da habe
ich jetzt 500 gramm ja das heißt für
mich ich werde jetzt erstmal die
mischung herstellen
nehmt euch am besten eine große schüssel
diesmal nicht gleich eine wo alles
reinpasst und ich brauche einen moerser
ich lass dir im ganzen nicht nur besser
war als ich noch ein moerser denn ich
habe hier die seltsamen und ihr könnt
das ganze auch in der gewürzmühle zwar
keine oder so ein bisschen zerstoßen mit
glas ich packe sie aber einfach alle
gewürze rein
zerstört es so ein bisschen
kommt alles in die große rührschüssel
die stärke dazu geben die stärke bildet
in dem fall dann auch die ganze
flüssigkeit die später austritt
knoblauchzehe rein und falls in der
knoblauch presse benutzt müsste sie auch
vorher schälen denn die knoblauchpresse
presst den ganzen inhalt an der schale
vorbei
spart man sich das und vor allem finde
ich es ganz gut dass man die
knoblauchzehen schälen muss die hände
richten dann nicht so dass ich mal ganz
praktisch jetzt noch balsamico und
olivenöl rhein
und die selbstgemachte gemüsebrühe da
gibt es schon ein video auf einem kanal
könnt ihr gerne machen immer wenn ich
gemüsereste hat vor allem sellerie und
keine seiner weste aber sellerie blätter
zum beispiel gebe ich da gern mit dazu
und etwas liebstöckel und einfach alle
gemüsereste die immer so anfallen und
dann verpackt ihr die schön und mixed
die mit salz und hab dann eine eigene
gemüsebrühe passte die im kühlschrank
lagern könnte dann einfach hier
dazugeben
und schön verrühren
[Musik]
das ist noch richtig herrliche marinade
nicht jetzt schon richtig gut und mir
läuft schon das wasser im mund zusammen
und jetzt nehme ich einfach alle zutaten
und schneit sie fein bei der paprika
macht das am besten so damit ihr
keinerlei paprika verluste habt drückt
ihr hier oben den stromkreis
dann löst er sich dann schneidet ihr den
boden weg
und könnte dann entweder hier
aufschneiden und dann einmal ein kranz
machen oder ihn schneidet einfach so
finde ich einfach alle vier seiten weg
und habe dann wie so eine art rechteck
kleine rechtecke
guckt mal und das haben wir jetzt auch
noch das heißt ihr habt das als müll und
habe keinerlei verluste und dann könnt
ihr hier nämlich die einzelnen teile
nehmen
und schön in streifen schneiden
und diesen deckel könnt ihr dann auch
einfacher streifen schneiden
[Musik]
das mit mir kochen
die kochen hähnchen mit gemüse
kommt doch bei den recht genau ganz toll
machst du das du kannst schon besser
zwiebel schell als der sturm ii
und da kann es schon besser
zwiebelschneiden als der leroy pass bloß
auf die sieht die ziele was ob das ist
eine abgekartete nummer gewesen von
anfang an
die werden nicht so schmidt
weltanschauung die wissen das doch als
wir bei behaupten es besser zwiebel
schälen als der sturm und besser
zwiebelschneiden als der aaron und
besser kochen als danny boyle
was sagst du dazu
okay so der papa hatte jetzt hier
geradezu seine veranstaltung also
airlines mit dabei und hilft mit fleißig
beim kochen leicht immer beim schälen
helfen
und du hast eben einen tipp für mich ne
wii was hast du gemeint mit dem dreck
auf der schale wie kriegt man den weg
ins auge krieg zwiebel säure
musste weinen
kummer wir wollen was machen möchtest du
verrühren oder möchtest du schneiden
[Musik]
verrühren du kannst dann einfach die
zutaten in die schüssel geben und mit
dem teig verrühren rheines lachen doch
beides mache natürlich weiter
dann gebe ich dir hier mal das kleine
messer super ich würde sage ich schneid
vielleicht die zwiebeln damit deine
augen nicht trennen oder sind wir beide
auch zwiebeln schneiden
guck mal ich mache was aber erst mal so
wir räumen erstmal hier auch dass wir
platz haben ja
weil was ist dann kochen immer ganz
wichtig auf rein
ja wir sind ein sauberer als der papa
wir räume ja
den ganzen müll einmal her habe ich
behalten schlaues kind
wem erkläre ich überhaupt was
du bist richtig schlau was man will
einfach hier stehen dem bio mülleimer im
ochsen zur seite
[Applaus]
warum ist es so wichtig beim beim kochen
sauber zu arbeiten dass meine zeit nicht
und ganz ordentlich arbeiten im laser
wieder
genau schön zu den streifen und wir
achten darauf dass wird die warte
charmant wir achten darauf dass wir die
finger zurücknehmen immer schön den
krallen grifka
angriff heißt nicht so nicht so wenn du
dann ausrutschte schneidest du in die
finger schauen finger zurück ja ein
bisschen ja
und wenn es gefährlich wird lieber mama
gehen
wenn es keine streifen sind einfach
aufessen platz genau dort dann steigen
wir jetzt die zwiebeln
aber sondern vielleicht das schotter
reinpacken
mal zusammen
alles da rein also bei dem rezept ist
tatsächlich einfach nur wichtig einmal
die marinade anrühren und da könnt ihr
das fleisch gemüse alles in die pfanne
geben er in den in den großen behälter
geben ihr könnt natürlich auch zuerst
das fleisch marinieren und später das
gemüse dazugeben das ist auch penny
hatte
stoppte fotos machte der runde setzen
rundes lebensmittel deswegen richtig zu
kurz so kummer immer so das ist der
tunnel griff
hat nein stopp nicht einfach mit druck
schneiden weil dann kann man ausrutschen
lieber lässt du dir hier helfen okay
guck mal sogar für mich ist schwer
und dann lieber flach hinlegen
und da ist die wurzel da schneiden wir
nicht sondern wir stehen auf der seite
und jetzt kommt der junior dünne
scheiben guck mal bei mir einfach dünne
schneiden schreiben
warte mal ich gebe dem motto ich geb dir
man zacken müsse sich halt es schneidet
die zwiebel besser dann hast du es nicht
so schwer weil man kannst du kannst du
so einmal durchsägen
so
nicht drücken sondern segen finger ich
ihn zurück
und jetzt staunen guck mal wenn's nur
noch so klein ist legen wir es hin
hinlegen oder
kippen was nach vorne und da kannst du
da noch streifen schneiden
immer auf die finger aufpassen das ist
wichtig
denn jetzt machen wir noch genau das
noch weg hauptsache die wurzel weg
sehr gut
sehr sparsam ja so super schwabe
gestohlen
und die zweite zwiebeln
das
[Musik]
halten wir für dich
weil die wurzel die ist ganz gut die
hält die zwiebel zusammen damit sie sich
auseinander fällt
hier schneiden
schön langsam
ich hab noch ein regenbogen
hervorragend jetzt ich schneide schon
mal das fleisch nicht schnell wir auch
hin streifen und wichtig ist wenn man
mit hähnchen arbeitet muss man danach
alles gut desinfizieren und deswegen
hähnchen immer zum schluss und dann
gleich messer weg brett weg alles
desinfizieren
hast du dir gemacht
deswegen da kann ich mit trug schneiden
ich habe kann ich nicht progressnow
hähnchen schneiden aber
vielleicht schneidig das hähnchen weil
ich dafür dass ganz scharfe messer
nehmen muss ich will jetzt nicht so ein
grosses mehr vergeben weil aber du
kannst auch schon mal verrühren
[Musik]
ich tue es mal kurz weg okay war sprit
meine hände des weins kommt
jetzt kann man mit sauberen händen warte
ich geb dir noch einmal ganz kurz einmal
runter dann mache ich noch eine anti
rutsch motto unter das die schüssel
nicht wegfällt
sondern silikon lotte und jetzt rutscht
es nicht weg
die
idee
vom papa geschaut
was hast du für eine idee alles wird das
doch ganz saubere hände kommt noch immer
so wenn das du einmal kurz verrühren so
viel zu wenig ungewöhnlich
du darfst ich kann dabei auf machen oh
da ist ein müll
mama hat auch eine größere chance nehmen
können wir euch
jetzt stehen pariert das ist alles gut
mariniert ist und dann können wir wie
gesagt die hähnchen gemüse mischung
entweder noch abgedeckt in den
kühlschrank stellen oder eben direkt zu
bereiten wir werden sie ganz kurz zur
seite stellen denn im prinzip angebraten
ist ja gleich und wir werden gleich noch
eine sour cream dazu zubereiten der
abokarte und gemüse zu schneiden mit
sour cream ist so eine vision abstand
creme wie so ein joghurt der joghurt
[Musik]
in kanto ja da auch so gemüse gab ja
kochen die da
ich finde sie schon ein bisschen aus wie
die von cantona
hat jedoch auch für kleider
pressebox essen
packen wir die daneben maps rein
ja okay das passt gut dann schöne hände
waschen mit viel seife
[Musik]
chefs kurz zur seite und zeigt euch
ebene zutaten für die st
bleib einfach noch lange ein kinderchor
versprichst du mir das so lange lange
langem ein kleines baby bleibt
[Musik]
so lange fern ihrer bleibe ich trinke ok
wird weist was schnittlauch ist wir
brauchen schnittlauch woher weißt du
dass
ich dachte es kommt jetzt so was wie ich
habe das schon mal meiner mama gelernt
jetzt kommt ich hab's schon im
kindergarten punkt
mittlerweile
so in etwa sieht
man die blumen
danke kommen wir mal zu
[Musik]
dann schneide ich jetzt schon mal den
schnittlauch
kannst ihn ausschneiden
hier halten vorsicht
schön die finger hinweg ja okay der rest
den brauchen wir nicht schneiden
wir warte mal bevor das rhein hochwasser
die
den schmand reiten oder crème fraiche
könnt ihr da auch nehmen creme fraiche
verschwand einfach und sauerrahm
die unterscheiden sich tatsächlich
geschmacklich im fettgehalt
dann etwas warte warte warte des
konzerns etwas mayonnaise
dann schnitt noch nicht alles noch mal
nur die hälfte
und dann war salz pfeffer und knoblauch
das kannst du und ich würde sagen weil
auch die der geduldsfaden so langsam
reißt und der hunger kommt machen wir es
einfach schon mal die pfanne heiß und
werden gleich unsere verriet pfanne
anbraten
ok
knoblauch packen noch rein aber am
besten nicht alle sind ist es schon so
viel weil ich mag den klub noch nicht so
dann holt du schon mal die rats wenn du
willst
dass man dir apps rennen das
[Musik]
ich gerne habe das schon mal die pfanne
erhitzt mit etwas olivenöl und jetzt
ratet ihr einfach das hähnchenfleisch
mit dem mühsamen business hähnchen gar
ist und wenn nicht alles in einer pfanne
papst da macht es einfach in zwei
portionen damit ihr schöne röstaromen
habt und eben das gargut die pfanne
nicht so kalt werden lässt
[Musik]
du bist ein leben das neben weiß dass
du bist der thomas als mädchen
[Musik]
jetzt hat er tatsächlich wieder haare
typischen quatschkopf und es wird sich
auch wieder thomas mädchen mama thomas
gesicht
okay das essen ist fertig vielen dank
fürs kochen mit ausprobieren hatte ihr
könnt jetzt entweder das ganze gericht
in einer süßen verrichte pfanne
anrichten das zeige ich euch gleich
erstmal kümmern wir uns um ella oder als
rap und er liebt ja raps das heißt ja
ich hole mal kurz gekommen dann finden
fleisch und gemüse
will ich da hast du aber magst du mir
noch helfen meinen zu gestalten
ein schönes
aber ich mich gleich zu klappen
ja stimmt und dann esse ich das herz
dann bist du immer in meinem herzen ja
dann aber kader und wissen limettensaft
könnte anhalten wird dann bereits so
so
moritz woher weißt du was burritos sind
sind die so gefüllt
und wenn man es ganz hübsch anrichten
möchte dann kann man es auch noch
aufschneiden
nämlich so
und kann ich dann auch so ein fähnchen
nehmen
und die hier reinstellen und
dann fangen wir ganz viel lernen
kann man sich das sogar als weg als
fingerfood wegnehmen gut dann gestaltete
mal deinen eigenen publikum
und dann mit probiert ja
[Musik]
was brauchst du ich bin bereit meine
palette
xaver okay
achso wo kleider profi trick natürlich
vielleicht nicht ganz bis zum rand ja
was möchtest du drauf auch hähnchen und
fleischer hähnchen und gemüse
vor lecker gekocht
was machst du dann
wird alles okay der grünen
oder noch mehr
wecken
natürlich
der sternekoch bist du
sternekoch
durch die falten hilft nicht du schaffst
es
[Musik]
guten appetit
gut gefüllt mit so das rezept
weiterempfehlen
dem hatten rodheim nicht so ein
sternekoch für dich
dem leser wird es besonders schmecken
mit dem sturm ii und dem arm grüße
ausrichten dass sie denen sagen
ja dann sagt sie ihnen ruhig also lieber
aaron und
sturmsolist rezept von händlern ruhig
auch mal nachmachen ja könnt ihr euch
tipps und tricks wurden bei ella
und weiter auch und weiterempfehlen sie
teilen sollen ok und teil das rezept
auch ganz gerne ok relativ schnaps den
teller ist am tisch ich mache hier noch
kurz fertig okay ich sage euch es
nämlich noch ganz kurz eine rest der
verwertungsmöglichkeit denn ihr könnt
die raps mit der verräter einfach jetzt
frisch essen oder das ganze auch am
nächsten tag oder am gleichen tag eben
auch überbacken dafür könnt ihr nämlich
die raps einfach füllen ganze in eine
auflaufform schichten und damit käse
überbacken ich zeige mich dass die
gemeinde die raps im ofen überbacken
wollt dann schneidet ihr am besten die
website bis hin zu dass sie perfekt in
die offen vom reinpassen dann kommt da
die verfüllung rhein mit hähnchen und
gemüse dazu gern ein bisschen sour cream
und die aber carola sie weg weil ich
persönlich war man auch karte und nicht
so gerne mag wie wir sind betroffen
dann das ganze schön zusammenrollen und
in die offene form schichten und gerne
könnt ihr das dann noch mit käse
überschütten und dann im ofen überbacken
und dann habt ihr eine richtig rechts
leckeres essen aber wie gesagt die
verräter schmeckt auch ganz gut 34 zu
servieren ihr könnt das ganze in raps
einrollen und auch so essen oder eben
überbacken das bleibt euch überlassen
probiert es rezept auch gerne mal aus
und schreibt mir euer feedback vor allem
ist es wirklich schnell das rezept nur
kurz gewürze zusammen hähnchen und
gemüse schneiden und das ganze dauert
vielleicht zehn minuten bis es dann in
der pfanne landet und dann habt ihr ein
geniales essen oder ihr habt direkt was
vorbereitet für den abend oder für den
nächsten tag falls ihr euch mehr solch
einfachen rezepte wünscht dann schreibt
mir gern in die kamera wir sehen uns
wieder beim nächsten mal vielleicht ist
und auch mal wieder dabei die ist
natürlich schon weg die hat sich aus dem
staub gemacht und mama dach schön allein
die küche kurz bis zum nächsten mal und
das kommt jetzt abgedeckt im kühlschrank
das erst noch morgen
[Musik]